when you do a lease option agreement
property and you buy it now
and agree to pay for it later and it
goes up in value maybe it doubles in
value
how do you finance it at the end of the
turn well i'm just about to speak to one
of my students
and she's about to complete on the end
of a lease option agreement
she's been in property now for almost 20
years let's see
how i can help and hopefully i'll be
able to help her out as much as i can
help you out with this youtube channel
do me a massive favor there subscribe
smash the like button and i'll jump on
the call right now
hello yeah i just i i got your message
in terms of the elite option situation
so i don't know if
you if you folks are happy to happen to
give my two pennies just for clarity
you've got
i'm alright thinking you've got a lease
option agreement you've had it eight
years
you've got an option to buy it for 165
grand
you want to exercise the option to buy
it but it's now worth
310 grand yeah nice
it is very nice it just is going to
cause you some problems with
the mortgage broker because they're
going to be like raising their eyebrows
on how you put it so cheap
yeah so there's a few things
you know that was the value eight years
ago
well it's brilliant absolutely i bet you
delighted that you secured that lease
option agreement now
yes very i think we actually um
bought that as a deal i think we paid
two grand for it
but not only that um we've been
renting it out for 30 odd grand a year
as well
oh goodness fantastic well
in terms of buying it now is it a hmo
roof
[Music]
okay okay so the value
right now is 310 is that commercial
value or is that bricks and mortar
um that seems to be the um bricks and
mortar valuations
based on sold prices in the area
okay and is the property currently
talented is it is it fully talented
yes it's full and they're all paying
okay
so so that so when do you want to buy
the property when do you want to
exercise your right to buy it
well this is we we're just um
speaking with steve at the moment about
releasing
the money out of the 12 bed that we've
got
and so i thought because i didn't know
what the best way to do it was whether i
need to buy it
cash and then mortgage it later or
whether there was like a
clever way of doing it and yeah
so basically what i'm thinking is at the
moment we're paying 700 pounds a month
um for the least i'm thinking
i could probably save money on the lease
yes i can actually you know because an
option is great
but it's never really in the bag until
it's in the bag
was the seller represented by a
solicitor when he signed the lease
option agreement
properly nice brilliant if i were you
i would be buying that house as fast as
i possibly
could yeah why'd you say that well
because
it's gone up in value it's like more
than doubled in value
almost like you don't want to be in a
situation whereby
the seller tries to now i've been i've
had situations before
very similar to this where the seller
will try and refuse to sell it to me
and they're like that they say i don't
want to change my mind oh i didn't know
what i was doing
now they've never won i've always
managed to buy the property when they've
done that
but it's just not it's just not nice
it's just a bit it's a bit
concerning when it happens when they
start saying i don't i didn't know what
i was signing in
you want the title deeds have you got a
restriction
have you got um are you on the title
dudes as
like you are oh brilliant so you should
be absolutely
fine now there are some problems that
you're going to find
if you try and buy that property right
now and you try and get a mortgage on it
it's going to be ah well you're buying
it for one sixth day
so you're gonna if you try and buy it
with a normal mortgage
the lender is gonna say how on earth
are you buying it so cheap and it's
gonna cause issues also
is the lease option agreement with
yourself or is it with a company or
who's
who's who's managing the contract i
think
i don't think that we oh good question
i can't remember to be fair but i don't
think that we have the limited company
then
right that's good that's good okay okay
that's good
um because another thing that's going to
happen is because honestly ruth i've
done this
so many times the last the last few
years
most of the properties that i've been
buying have been properties that
are secured in a lease option agreement
like seven years ago
so you know i've done this so many times
and i've had some i've had some right
fun and games because what the lenders
say is the lender's side that if you've
got an interest in the property they
don't want to lend to you
right because they think it's like a
conflict of interest they also
don't like it when the property is so
heavily below market value
the best way to purchase that property
now would be to buy either cash or on a
bridging loan
yeah then spend five or ten thousand
pounds getting some new carpets and some
new paints
yeah but the thing is we we just
refurbished it oh last year oh
that's that's it that's that's
unfortunate timing
i would i would probably just spend a
couple thousand
giving it that fresh new smell as if
it's just been refurbed like last week
and then that way the valuer will think
oh you bought it for 165
but you probably have spent like 100
grand
doing some wacky conversion because they
don't know what the what the state of
the property was like when you bought it
even if you buy it cash 160 or get a
bridging loan
and then it gets down valued massively
you're still going to be able to pull
all your money out
yeah i know yeah so there's no issues so
that's what i would do have you
have you got the couch to buy it um
not just at this second but like i say
we're just
remortgaging our twelve beds with
these yeah going through now so as soon
as we've got the cash for that
then through from that then that should
be enough but it will probably take you
a few
a few weeks at least to complete on the
property anyway so what you could do is
you could start
getting the ball rolling on buying this
property
and then by the time you come to
complete you'll have the money from the
refinance
yeah but then will the money have to sit
in the
in this property for six months before
we can pull it out
it won't have to it depends on who the
lender is there are some lenders that
will let you refinance straight away
like kent reliance and precise
but but it's gonna it's gonna open you
up to a lot more lenders
if you just wait six months but you know
what who cares it's only six months and
then you're gonna be able to
pull all your money and a load more back
out i would be
wanting to get the keys to that lease
option i know you've already got the
keys but i would be wanting to get the
title deeds i should say
to that property like asap
yeah because the longer you leave it the
longer the refurb look it doesn't look
as brand new and
i would be but i definitely think buying
it cash is going to be your best bet
whether it be through bridging
whether it be through um you know
a refinance on another property i you
don't have to buy cash but i just think
with the with the amount it's
appreciated in value it's going to raise
too many red flags to the lender um
you know they're going to be so confused
over it i know i've done it i've done it
so many times
um so i would i'd be buying it quick and
i'd be buying
cash um and then probably putting the
money out but it sounds like a cracking
deal bet you're over the moon
yeah because we've been looking you know
for comparables
and what i didn't realize was that um
some of the
figures i was comparing it to
were the same but without the basement
done it's still on the cellar
and then when i realized like a couple
of days ago
actually the reason why some of the
houses in this street are like 300 grams
and some are like you know 160 70 grams
because some of them don't have
themselves converted which i was done
yeah so it was a bit of a light bulb
moment brilliant
brilliant but yeah if you and if you
need anything else just give me a shout
let me know what happens but
yeah it sounds it sounds like you're in
a really strong position listen i'll
just talk to you anything else give me a
shout out
wow lease option agreement eight years
ago had the option to buy it
for 185 now
it's worth 310 and now
they're thinking how we're gonna now
finance this but frick
they're in a good position these option
agreements they really do work